حيث قررت المحكمه الاسرائيليه العليا
ارجاء تطبيق التعديل الذي اقره الكنيست
على احد القوانين المتعلقه بمنع عزل رئيس
الحكومه باعتباره تشريعا شخصيا واساءه
لاستخدام السلطه من قبل رئيس الوزراء
بنيامين نتنياهو وقضت المحكمه بان يدخل
التعديل على القانون الى حيز التنفيذ خلال
دوره الكنيست المقبل اي بعد اجراء
انتخابات برلمانيه عامه جديده وهو ما يمكن
المستشاره القضائيه للحكومه من الاعلان عن
عزل نتنياهو وكان الكنيست قد صدق في مارس
اذار الماضي على تعديل قانون يحول دون ذلك
ويسمح فقط لرئيس الحكومه بعزل نفسه او عبر
اغلبيه من 90 عضوا في الكنيست وهو التعديل
الذي سعى اليه نتنياهو لتحصين نفسه من
العزل بسبب قضايا الفساد التي يحاكم عليها
اعود لك سيد ابراهيم ربايعه وهي مساله
سببت جدل كبير في داخل تل ابيب وهددت
بنيامين نتنياهو كثيرا وكان هناك مظاهرات
عديده تتعلق بهذا الامر الان يحصل ما لا
يرغب فيه بنيامين نتنياهو
تعليقك العرف الذي كان سائد في السياسه
الاسرائيليه بان رئيس الوزراء في حال وجهت
له لائحه اتهام او بدات التحقيقات في
قضايا فساد يقدم استقالته وهذا حدث سابقا
مع اول مارت جاء نتنياهو وضمن منظومه
التحصين لشخصه ولليمين وفي ظل القضايا
التي كانت تواجهه ايه وضع هذا القانون
لحمايه نفسه من الاقاله وبالتالي تاتي
المحكمه العليا وتقوم بهذا القرار والذهاب
الى هذا القرار وابطال هذا القانون بعد ان
قامت بتعطيل قانون المعقوليه وعدم
المعقوليه ايه وهي تاتي لتفكيك المنظومه
القانونيه التي نشات خلال الفتره السابقه
بما سمي الانقلاب القضائي وبالتالي تعيد
حاله التوازن بين السلطات في النظام
السياسي وتفقد اليمين لادوات الضاغطه
اليوم تستثمر المحكمه العليا هذه اللحظه
التي يبدو فيها نتنياهو باكثر حالاته من
الضعف اليمين بحاله ايضا ضعف وحاله اهتزاز
لا يوجد قدره وفق التفاهمات التي تمت مع
بيني جانس بالذهاب الى الكنيست من اجل
المناقشه لتشريعات بعيده عن حاله الحرب
وبالتالي تثمر هذه الفرصه لاستعاده حاله
القدره للمحكمه العليا تحديدا وهي السلطه
التي بامكانها البث في كل القرارات تعطيل
القرارات تعطيل القوانين
بالان القانون السابق الذي تم تعطي هو
قانون اساس وهو بمستوى دستوري وبالتالي من
المتوقع ان تشهد المرحله القادمه مزيد من
تفكيك المنظومه القانونيه التي انشاها
نتنياهو واليم المتطرف من رام الله
ابراهيم ربايعه الاكاديمي والباحث في
العلوم السياسيه شكرا ي ل